does Noah Cyrus want to join fifth  harmony they're like the sweetest ever  [Music]  the band is down a member since Camilla  Kibeho announced she was leaving the  group in December to go solo but on  Wednesday Miley's little sister stopped  by Elvis Duran and the morning show to  chat about her new music and offered  herself up as Camilla's replacement I  want to do a song with fifth harmony  they're like my favorite and like I love  that they're hiring harmony the  seventeen-year-old even has a title for  their first single I think if we had a  song and have to be called like bad  girls or something like just something  for extra for now the group is staying a  foursome and told Billboard that on  their upcoming record their quote  experimenting with a lot of different  sounds on Thursday the band released the  music video for their first single  without Camila and it definitely had us  getting down  [Music]  you